it would break everyone's mind i i don't
know if i want it but it would break
everyone's mind i mean it'd be pretty
beautiful to behold oh it's that thing
you said a million times before it's
like i don't necessarily want it but if
it happens i'm gonna be losing my [ __ ]
[Music]
well if it ain't squid game it's
spider-man we got some spider war and
crap to check out today spider-man no
way home
second trailer leaked description scenes
stuff now let's see if any of this comes
true give our two cents to see if we
believe any of this it's not like we
believe anything take everything with a
grain of salt lead with doubt what's
going on everybody it's warren welcome
back to the cosmic wonder where we talk
all things marvel and mcu and today we
have something very very interesting to
talk about there has been a supposed
leaked description for the second
spider-man knowing home trailer that
would be the official trailer since the
first trailer that we got although it
was freaking awesome was only a teaser
just a teaser it's not enough is wanting
tobey maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man to show up in this
official trailer so we know that they're
in the movie before it comes out and
according to this trailer description
that i'm about to go over they are and
this won't be the first report that
we've gotten some other people like big
screen leaks have also reported that in
the final shot of the official trailer
we're going to see the other two
spider-man with tom holland and i think
that's all we really really want from
the trailer in all honesty just show up
start going over this description of
what this second trailer is supposedly
going to be now i gotta add that this is
not confirmed to be what the actual
trailer is going to be it does line up
with well yeah of course
that's why it's a weak and a rumor
posting this there's no way to tell if
it's real or fake however it's still
very interesting to think about and
hopefully this actually is what we see
because it's very intriguing now here
are the photos that were shared it makes
it look like these photos were kind of
like swiped from a computer screen or
something like if they are real somebody
took a picture of them and they weren't
supposed to but who knows so i'll read
exactly what it says
someone shot their notepad spiderman no
way home exclusive trailer 2 leaked
description authority and ownership sony
pictures they state that like that's
actually going to help them
talking about the court that's the next
day ned tells him that he is a minor and
they cannot put him in without an
extension peter tells them not to let
them be in danger which i think actually
means peter tells them that they are not
in danger and i should have added that
this was actually i think translated
from russia so the translation won't
match up exactly peter says it is no
longer the world
when it cuts to the sony and marvel logo
there are repeated scenes from the first
trailer but in this trailer the spell of
strange is better explained and we see
different scenarios of different
villains from other sagas we see the
scene where doc ock appears on the
bridge and talks to peter parker and
peter says to him who are you and what
do you want and doc ock replies with i'm
finishing what i started
finishing what he started being
that
big sun energy source yeah he just whips
out a big fireball right there
i can continue i can i can finally
rebuild and get my rosalie back yeah
yeah the portal opens up and not only
does ock get sucked through but the
actual energy source coming right
it then says we hear willem dafoe's
green goblin speaking to tom holland
spider-man saying in my twisted ways i
asked for your help i admit it i am
aggressive but that is my nature and
then it says these words are
complimented by a scene where we see all
the villains and peter seeing all the
villains surprised we then see a
disembodied sandman in a cell we see the
lizard and then we see elektro making a
huge lightning storm we can see
lightning strike the city and we can see
all of the villains we hear the words of
doctor strange speaking to peter parker
saying the multiverse is just one
percent of what we know if you mess with
reality enough it will end up affecting
yours we then see peter kissing mj and
we see ned crying then it says we see
the trial of peter parker then a shot of
a fight with lizard in the subway that's
interesting because peter parker's had
fights on subways several times by this
point toby mcguire fought doc hawk on
the subway
sad man got his head hit on a subway
train oh yeah true
andrew garfield didn't go
left him like a whole laboratory in the
subway and that's where he discovered
his powers
so subway seemed to be an important
aspect here yeah the underground man or
spiders like to hang out a common
location in new york city for spider-man
and five people and then swinging over
yellow cabs you got to get all the
transportation you got to stop a train
it says that the sixth member of the
sinister six is rhino from the amazing
spider-man 2. and this is something that
has been kind of rumored but not
confirmed in any way i've been hearing
that as a common rumor that he would be
the sixth member of the sinister six for
some reason i'm having a hard time
wrapping my head around that only
because it seemed to be just a really
terrible response then again elektra
wasn't exactly beloved either but at
least it's jamie foxx we know the
potential but same thing can be said for
paul giamatti the difference to me is
just that paul giamatti felt like a bit
character like a comic strip out of the
graphic novel of those movies so it
would feel almost a little tactile like
what why him versus like a shocker or
versus you know any number of other
incidental villains we've seen acro why
not vulture vulture would be way more
tom paul and villain yeah yeah yeah
exactly and especially if you're gonna
bring multiples from the other two why
not have only one for tom holland we see
doctor strange taking peter through the
multiverse we then see peter in his new
black and gold suit fighting against
electro in the sky it then cuts to the
spider-man no way home logo it then
shows us one last scene of the trailer
which shows the three spider-man
fighting together against the sinister
six it says the two other spider-man do
not remove their maps but they have the
same costumes as their respective
characters meaning toby mcguire is
wearing his outfit from the sam raimi
spider-man universe and andrew garfield
is wearing his from the amazing
spider-man universe now if this is what
happens i'm really really okay with this
in fact i hope this is actually what we
see i don't actually want to see too
much of the movie with this trailer what
i really want for this trailer to do is
simply establish that these villains are
from the other universes there are still
people out there saying that doc ock and
the green goblin and all these other
villains could be from other universes
than the ones we've already seen and
that they could just be variants and not
actually from the tobey maguire universe
in andrew garfield universe so i'd like
established clarity on where exactly
they're from okay yeah it would be way
too confusing if they just were like no
let's just bring them back to play these
roles i think that would just confuse
the hell out of audiences if they did
something like that and it's very
apparent that marvel has been building
it up yeah i think even evan peters as
ralph boder is somewhat of a
semi-preparation but there's a
possibility they can do that and of
course by this point you guys who are
watching the video because i know the
venom two post-credits scenes they can
pull from other movie franchises
mcu yeah absolutely but there is
something that i do really love about
the idea of seeing the established
sinister six and then just seeing the
shot of the other two spiderman because
then it would just make the whole thing
feel that much more complete as a tease
for okay i get why all these villains
are here further cements the necessity
to having the other two spider-man be in
this movie i i just feel like that
trailer shot would just be freaking
insane it would break everyone's mind i
i don't know if i want it but it would
break everyone's mind it'd be pretty
beautiful to behold oh it's that thing
you said a million times before it's
like i don't necessarily want it but if
it happens i'm gonna be losing my [ __ ]
so hopefully we learn a little bit more
about the villains and where they come
from now it also says that dr strange's
spell is explained and i think this is
something that we could use some clarity
on as well who remembers him who doesn't
know it's him does ned know it's him mj
what exactly is he in for and then of
course it ends by saying that we do see
the three spider-man what we really want
is that confirmation in the trailers
that's what we're all just holding out
for just show us and confirm now one
thing that this that's awesome scared of
is that rhino was going to be the sixth
member of the sinister six and it also
does mention the lizard which we kind of
saw in the first trailer it's still very
hard to make out if that is indeed the
lizard or
venom no no no that's not venom that's
not venom i just don't think it would
make as much sense it wouldn't make any
sense it's clear that the lineup of what
they're doing and i think at what point
you can't see a tail i think in a
certain shot but beyond that too it's it
it's also there's a correlation kind of
like the symmetry of all these people
that you have here
it would just line up that it's lizard
yeah you got people pulling from the
toby mcguire well people followed from
the andrew garfield one and so far venom
hasn't been pitted against any one of
the three spiderman tom hardy's venom
specifically and there's no way in hell
they're going to bring back topra
grace's venom for this hey parker nah
nah i'm completely unsold on that when i
was first presented to me i was like
maybe i just saw venom but after
thinking about it no i don't i don't
believe it at all mid-credit scene
symbiote lands on earth
why would the symbiote land on earth
because
uh
that's a good point
because they already got venom in the
new spot never mind
i don't know to maybe establish
something with peter parker before they
just cross them over no just cross them
over john skip steps i know and the only
thing that's kind of weird about this is
that we already have established
villains inside of the mcu and it
doesn't look like we're going to be
seeing any of them in this film or if we
do maybe it's just going to be briefly
there's been no mention or leaks or
anything about vulture about scorpion
chameleon the tinker nothing legos
yeah they have been legos
from the police
and we know that doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is going to kind
of be dealing with the repercussions of
spider-man knowie home and a bunch of
other projects as well then it does make
sense that the villains are going to be
from other universes so i think if this
is the trailer that we get a lot of
people will be excited especially if
they do show the three spiderman at the
end but i stand by what i said hoping
that we don't get shown too much of the
other two spider-man in the trailer but
let me know what you think in the
comments down below would you rather see
them in the trailer or not wait till the
film let me know and don't forget to
like this video and for live updates you
can always find i already like instagram
and twitter i verbally thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
well yeah i think that if they are in it
i think you they would be fools to not
let people know because you got to have
people who aren't following this
obsessively and you want to hook them
too and those people will inevitably
some of them be familiar with those old
movies enough to get excited yeah well
i'm just saying this movie probably cost
them like 500 million dollars to put
together especially if they were able to
get
toby maguire out from the forest where
he was chopping yeah i'll only come out
for 50 million dollars yeah like you
know he costs a lot of money to be like
all right fine i'll do it you'd have to
show like let them allude that they were
in it or else i think they'd be wasted
potential waste of money yeah especially
when
even though then electric carnage broke
its record from the first venom movie
and that was during like the time of a
pandemic but still you got that caveat
that you are working up against so if
you want to just solidify that you're
not gonna have to even worry about it
you want to solidify that billion yeah
yeah it's robin
all right guys well what do you think
about this piece of information i feel
like we learned kind of some new things
i can guarantee you that the sony logo
the marvel logo and the title the movie
will show up in the second trailer so at
least those parts are accurate shut up
meg
all right guys hey thank you warren for
putting this together you sexy son of a
[ __ ]
end the video